welcome to hose tech and tutorial why
hasn't there been a third coding name
reactions
I'll explain nobody watches it that's
why okay so I opened a bunch of stuff
from programming humor I haven't looked
at these yet so I don't know what I'm
getting into we're gonna see them both
at the same time are you ready for
coding name reactions and undecided name
the game let's not forget if you relate
to one of these posts you win
what do you win you win the day you win
life you've been relating to sarcastic
usually not funny people Amazon
engineers be like oh great I've been
looking at code for the last four hours
and now I finally get to see a little
duck instead and oh it just made my day
seeing this little duck in the code I oh
my goodness someone soaked who cares
you're probably an adult or mostly an
adult who cares about a stupid duck
saying meow alright next one excellent
it's interesting that they have software
programming dexta the unexplained enough
we keep seeing a repeating a repeating
meme where people associate programming
and software engineering with magic
ghostly presence things that are just
totally unexplained it's mathematical
not ghostly and unexplained so stop stop
posting that crap who else is a novice
and that relates to this ranch dressing
delicious the scent the software
engineers guide to asserting dominance
yes please give me something funny
stupid Quintero
as a software engineer changing your
hubs is a way of life it is not hard to
get a job in further are you having
trouble are you having trouble getting
job as a programmer here's what you do
work on stuff update your CV work on
stuff update your CV send it to
companies send it to recruiters whatever
you know all that stuff will get you a
job so there you go
if you're working on stuff you're
learning you're getting better here
updating your CV people are gonna
understand what you can do they'll offer
you stuff ok let's let's go first day of
work focus entirely on physical
establishment on this office humans are
hard-wired Paulo the biggest sister
presents just in case you don't know
just just you know I fix that for you
version this should actually probably
Tuesday Mondays display of physicality
this is funny though I like this you
need to spend Tuesday getting your
develop environments the hard-boiled
eggs sporadically throughout the day but
save one now this actually do not take
any breaks up to mix protein shakes and
remember you should be consuming one
gram of protein per pound of body weight
or 100 per line of code written
whichever is great okay
well what should you actually be doing
on the second day yeah you should be
setting up your environment spend the
rest of the day familiarizing yourself
with the team's codebase it seems like
half of this is right and half of its
kind of the joke if your team doesn't
use git announce your resignation
immediately and walk out I would say
this is probably actually good advice in
general that's a pretty big sign if your
team doesn't use git they're way behind
on the times they probably don't know
what they're doing it's generally safe
to assume I mean maybe they do I could
be very wrong but it's a it's a pretty
good indicator that someone doesn't know
how to code is they don't know get
essentially to sweat damn you should be
basically angry
mumble words like refactor rewrite on
your breath start drawing random complex
architecture diagrams on your whiteboard
yeah that's that will establish not only
dominance but a high form of annoyance
it would probably be about this time
that your boss is like I don't think
this job is for you and send you home so
that's not very good for dominance when
you get fired early if I had a new guy
come in and he was visibly angry on the
second day by 3:00 p.m. and trying to
rewrite everything I'd probably be like
okay what's your plan and I sit him down
and I'd listen to him and see what plan
he's coming up with and if it sounds
horrendously terrible and misguided or
just want to you know try to act like a
badass I would say I don't think this
positions for you this is gonna suck to
cut this video look how many more I got
to be quicker Wednesday's Wednesday's
this time is to your technical
sovereignty
too painful to read I'm trying to find
the hidden thing to it like it's flat on
both sides obviously you can flip it
upside down I love this reaction though
it's like what why is this session as
amazement for both of these guys I guess
it's flat on both sides of course you
can flip it up so 10 flies 10 amazing oh
my god
hmm I'm so impressed with her cable me
too
that's really impressive instead of
unsubscribing from this annoying email
chain I just allowed to continue
terrorizing me for months because
apparently cooking three buttons is too
much for my busy schedule I'm gonna I'm
gonna go with I don't care on that one I
mean I know there's a lot of I don't
cares in here but really it's just not
funny who cares I'm [ __ ] care why is
this some programming humor this
programming humour sucks
am I wrong one again oh my god I think I
am geez let's see if any of them are not
complete turd it doesn't work why it
work with wife I don't know why it
doesn't work does work look at your own
damn code all I see his pictures of your
stupid face and your crappy comment
securities like a condom I was
explaining security with a friend to
another friend my friend just said
security protections like technology is
wearing a condom some people go without
so people always use it and even
sometimes it breaks do you want to know
what Security's really like do you want
to know yellow blitz why do characters
and movies have such a hard time even a
eyes from turning evil oh my god it's
part of the plot let's let's keep going
don't give up now not yet
we got a few more implementation this is
the code base
it's amazing how such a small thing
you can do so much
I like this finally one that's half
decent yeah people try to tell you
programming simple and then where it
really starts getting confusing which is
when you start tying a whole bunch
things together and they want you to
look at the front code and be like it's
simple see like yeah it's simple when
you have all this stuff ready good luck
with all that it's not that bad I mean
you just do it piece by piece walk
through to walk through technical manual
through technical manual you know you
just got to go for it
hey I'm glad they upgraded snail 2.00
new version was too slow okay yeah nice
try I mean I get it but yes clients mess
everything up that's why you gotta make
your stuff better what do you want
especially our registers on the website
there Connie how did you fix oh I hid
all the error messages is this really
supposed to be funny
14.2 KF folks
I mean okay if you're actually someone
and have someone working on your website
and you respond like this their opinion
of you is just going to drop it's not
going to be funny still haven't related
yeah I will take over the world what
people say eh I can do mwah-ha-ha-ha
meanwhile I found Waldo yep
that's kind of cool that they made one
that can find water wall though but come
on this what why is it funny to keep
talking about AI taking over the world
like that's the oldest most dead thing
ever
people have been talking about that
since like I don't know the concept of a
I even came about it's it's not humorous
it's just like okay
that that argument that's been beaten to
the ground for eternity right let's have
some let's have a laugh over it again
yet again who cares I don't think I'm
gonna win this one I've won the last two
but this one this is really it's really
letting me down I'm having a rough this
is gonna be a rough day you know I'm not
winning the day so okay at least it's
not as bad as Java classes makes name
unique and descriptive keeps line under
seventy nine characters Python
developers keep lines okay I guess I
gotta go to the comments cuz I don't
find this at all and anyway relatable or
funny okay
how about not nesting everything seven
seven layers deep but using a decent
level of abstraction so you can do both
this both and split the line if it still
gets too long 114 points but the route
the response to this 235 I'm sorry but
that's not how my grandma I think to
make spaghetti that's a quality no I
can't relate though because my grandma
didn't teach me to make spaghetti okay
last one can we win will this one do it
if someone dies on a flight what is
their time of death is it the time zone
that came from the one they are reaching
or even the one they are currently in as
they are flying this has nothing to do
with programming humor oh my god I lost
lost and
didn't win today
this has been coding meme reactions
totally original show never ripped
anyone off ever
if you related one I did not relate to
any of this I thought all those were
pretty terrible
okay see you in the next one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
you